شواهد قبور ضحايا الزلزال باتت تميز
بالارقام بدلا من الاسماء
فالتعرف على هويه الضحايا لم يعد متاحا
لذويهم امام حجم الكارثه
[موسيقى]
قوه زلزال عند سبع درجات لم تسجل في
التاريخ الا 20 مره كان اخرها
ثمانيه عام 2015 حينها اودى بتسعه الاف
شخص
لك عوامل اخرى غير حركه الطبقات التكتونيه
كانت وراء وقوع هذه الاعداد الضخمه
[موسيقى]
غاده الزلزال في الرابعه صباحا جعلت
النائمون يجدون انفسهم عالقين عندما
انهارت منازلهم فضلا عن تاخر استجابه اطقم
الاغاثه في هذه الساعه المبكره
عشر ولايات ضربها الزلزال شتت جهود عمليات
الانقاذ من حيث تحديد اولويه المناطق
الاكثر احتياجا
فالساعات الذهبيه هي الاولى في عمليات
الانقاذ لكنها جاءت متاخره بفعل انهيارات
الطرق المؤديه الى المواقع المتاثره ليصل
بعضهم في اليوم الثاني والثالث الى تلك
الوجات
مخالفه متعهد البناء لمعايير مقاومه
الزلزال التي تفردها التشريعات في تركيا
على وقع زلزال عام 1999
سيدي الحديدي العربيه